catastrophic new economic numbers
showing why lockdown protesters like the
Dallas salon owner are desperate to get
back to work over 20 million jobs were
lost in the month of April alone that is
the worst monthly loss ever recorded
President Trump
reacting earlier today as 40 states have
plans to reopen their economies in some
form we're going into transition and I
call it transition to greatness it's
going to be transition to greatness
because we're going to do something very
fast and we're going to have a
phenomenal year next year Jesse I wanted
to start with you so a transition to
greatness there's not a switch to
reopening the economy and especially in
businesses where capacity is reduced and
staff has been diminished but how and
why should we maintain a favorable
positive outlook on the future because
we're Americans and that's what
Americans do they're hopeful they're
optimistic and we always win it's funny
because you know the president
historically he's always I guess in his
personal and professional life you know
you see these big ups and then these big
downs you know the the rise and then the
fall the rise in the fall you know he
had the greatest economy ever and now
it's the worst economy ever but as
Donald Trump gonna come back yeah
because he always does and America
always comes back and we're gonna come
back together what you're seeing now are
numbers that you can't even really make
sense of it's kind of like Obamacare
when you saw these just crazy premiums
up a hundred and fifty percent and then
the media would say oh it's doing great
until you talk to someone that had
Obamacare and told you how their
deductibles went up astronomically then
you really see it I don't even know if
anybody in the media knows one person
that's been laid off because of the
pandemic and what you're starting to see
is class warfare in America but in
Reverse you're seeing the top people
kind of shake their fist down at
everybody else you have to stay down you
have to stay in your home and you have
to do this because I said so but the
rest of the country is saying we got to
go to work and they're starting to
resent that and you can see it's a
collision course and it's coming and I
know who's gonna win one to Jesse's
point about sort of the regional
locations if you take that from a state
and local standpoint what is your
position on letting the states and
governors and local city officials have
more control over their small business
owners requirements so the president
obviously has delegated a lot to the
governor's including the reopening but
what about things like cure periods and
whatnot with a PPP like if a state and
in if a state isn't open yet shouldn't
they have more time to pay back etc oh
sure I think that you know the
governor's have had that kind of
authority all along Emily but I think
they still have it I don't think
anybody's contesting that the president
is simply offering guidelines and I
think some of the problems here is that
the states many of the states that are
reopening I think more than half don't
meet the current phase 1 guidelines but
I think everybody I know from my heart I
wish the economy could get back to
normal right now but to just say like
magically you know open up right away
everybody it just poses such great risk
because if we get back into a situation
where we see those numbers start to
climb again then it's not only more
people getting sick but you're also
going to see an escalation in terms of
an unemployment which as you pointed out
is now you know near great depression
numbers and we don't want to see that so
I don't think it's a matter of anybody
kind of shaking their fist and telling
people what to do I think that even the
opinion polls show overwhelmingly most
Americans Republican Democrat
independent think we have to be cautious
we can't be imprudent and say oh let's
just rush out as if everything is
suddenly going to be ok it could look
good for the moment and then two weeks
from now because that's how long it
takes for this disease to take root
we'll be back in the in a worse
situation we don't want that Dana you've
shown such compassion for those who are
going hungry and might find themselves
in a position where they are unable to
ask for help
we have Shelley Luther who said
I just couldn't bring myself to
apologize for wanting to go back to work
what are your thoughts on that well I do
admire her you know that saying that not
all heroes wear capes and I think for
for people who understand you know the
situation from her point of view she is
definitely a hero I did think that it
was brilliant for senator Ted Cruz to
organize to fly up from Houston to go to
have his hair cut there and I also
admire him for wearing a mask and
showing that you know there are ways
that we can get back to work safely or
get back to our businesses that we
frequent or that we want to visit for a
service and I thought that was smart
because there are there is a way as the
president said this transition back to
greatness that's going to require us to
maybe do with something a little bit
different and I think our public leaders
if they are willing to get out there and
show the way then other people might
follow and we can do this safely and
prudently and get people back to work so
that they don't have to join a food line
Greg what are your thoughts on any of
the above
I just don't know a single person who's
saying let's rush out I don't know a
single person who's saying you know
screw caution I want to open up right
away even if people die this is such a
myth okay we try to resist this on this
show but we keep getting pulled back
into the prison of two ideas which I am
so sick of hearing myself say but the
but we keep some people are saying
people who say open up and other people
take shut down no everybody has been
saying the same thing the solution is in
between those two polls that's all we've
been talking about and yet if we admit
that then we lose that we lose the
dramatic nature of saying oh but people
will die people will die it's like we no
one is saying we're going to magically
open we're talking about phased Rhee
openings we're talking about protecting
the vulnerable we were talking about
making changes that can then be reversed
if and when the disease comes back
everybody is adults are weighing the
benefits and the risks every time they
open their mouths
there is nobody nobody
that just saying hey it's reckless by
the way 66% let's go back to that number
that Cuomo was talking about 66% of the
new patients were indoors and isolating
meaning they were staying in so we have
to start thinking about what's happening
there is that the secret sauce is shared
ventilation which you see in cruise
ships you see in office buildings you
see in rest homes you see in airplanes
is shared ventilation in issue here is
shared ventilation in parks not so much
I think you're gonna see more research
on the correlation between low vitamin D
levels and disease natural vitamin D
levels and I remember very early in on
this epic about this pandemic when
people would talk about the the science
of weather in the science and sunshine
and people mocking that you're gonna
find out that maybe it wasn't right to
mark that that being outside is going to
be part of this solution